[Music]
in catfish and murder news oh god that's
delicious and with that submitted by
Jalen send love to the JK crews Thank
You Dada and and catfished her niece on
Facebook to keep an eye on her and its
horrified to discover that her niece is
planning on killing her lesson is that
is trying to catfish the nice that's the
type of ad that mean every niece wants
to murder she should be proud that our
nieces gangsters but and she doesn't
really have to protect her that chooses
and that's the reason why she would
catch about catfishing like my little
brother I'm like some [ __ ] Nigerian
prince and I'm doing whatever he's like
[ __ ] imma [ __ ] kill your ass on my
hey yeah my little brother's hot but
while you're scared for your life yeah
nobody saying like I'm gonna kill my
brother
oh it still my brother chewing the khaki
shirt yeah yeah so on also she revealed
to the catfish ooh that's gonna kill the
on yeah oh yeah that is [ __ ] weird is
this Patra it's a perfect expression
she's like you're gonna do what yeah
like I caught dang she got that long
focal length on that land extra blurry
right yeah so this is her traumatic you
have a non zero zero so the odds back in
2014
took her 22 year-old niece in and what
else again the report it didn't saying
why she took her Neeson it's just I all
we know is that she was housing honey
that's what happens when you try to do
charitable work probably isn't the
lesson here but well usually this
happens a lot of people like because
their parents something happened to go
in with it at the end who can't have
babies and it's a reason why God didn't
wanted our babies because she's [ __ ]
batshit crazy and it's a terrible
experience living with her what the kid
could be a psychopath mmm and they just
belong on a longboard all benefit this
is Marissa the 22 year old Z it looks
familiar
why does she have a 1998 Asian gangster
haircut she looks crazy now on she
decided to keep an eye on Marissa
by creating a facebook profile under the
name of Trey topp dogg's Ellis
that's tight just another reason why she
decided to pass Fisher you've been
connecting with a lot of people online
and just like going out with them so
he's concerned yeah but you just want to
make sure that her niece is safe right
and so there was this time when the
niece was talking to Trey right and like
apparently they were like they were
setting up a date to actually meet up
with each other right and they set up a
date to like meet up at a time where
Marissa couldn't go out and so the law
on purposely on that specific night of
her and Trey's date like she was like oh
you can't go out like me to stay home
right and so what the niece would do is
she would be like messaging Trey's like
oh my god looking hey my aunt you know
like like I feel so trapped she won't
let me see you both my auntie miss don't
know [ __ ] about me I'm pretty [ __ ]
crazy
you got to get me out of here I hate her
I hate everyone here I know how I can
see you like come to my house kill my
aunt kill them all and a dog might a dog
yeah she might just be saying that at a
rage but not really meaning it it's not
rage talk once you include this dog
because dogs took on the personality of
the owner so she owned like the aunt
should [ __ ] about either and also
depends on what kind of conversations
they had prior with top dog because the
top dog was like I'm a killer got out of
jail I do do all these things and then
she's actually requesting him to do all
these things and it could be serious
with hot dog is the answer but his
persona like the persona could have been
like yo I'm Trey top dog I just got out
of jail I'm a crazy-ass [ __ ]
killed five people just set up your
maybe she's doing all of that to set up
breast life to see if her little niece
is gonna like why do they know like yo
you're bad news you what if she was like
oh you made me so horny with all those
harm to my knees is stupid - so the way
that top dog
talked to Marissa top dog yeah talk to
Marissa like when she was like laying
all that stuff like he was just saying
like oh like this isn't for real right
you know wants us to happen she was like
no I want you to kill her like she
confirmed that like she wants her aunt
dead holy she might be living out of
Fanta
say it doesn't matter like I don't know
too many people that have verbally told
a stranger that they want to murder
think about the kind of offices she
created a 22 year old girl a fake page
and then catfished her I'm with you
there up to say oh she want a date with
the dude that she knows she probably
picked the right picture kind of guy
that she likes and then sabotage the
date right well we don't realize though
is both of these fools are [ __ ] crazy
and they're related by that so I run in
the family
all I'm saying is is that even though
one person is crazy the other president
want to murder the other person good
point
I'm a top dog with a charming man and a
charming man is very hard to resist or
anyone do I hate the answer unless look
at this one a [ __ ] profile perfect
professional ass photos the shape of
herself looking on disapproving I better
than knowing as how I'm skeptical look
at her but she's on the laptop look a
photo sure she did a disapproving laptop
photos like this is what I looked like
when I was top dog wasn't the Moto done
by the publication it's the news that
covered her translational lifestyle [ __ ]
out of everything don't they like for
the on like she got really scared
because the niece gave like really
detailed information on like how to kill
dawn like how to get into the house like
how to break into the room and then like
the nice even said like I have a
suitcase like with all my clothes packed
and I'm ready to go but kudos to her I'm
digging that elephant in the background
I like that I bet you she got it in
Thailand when she visited white elephant
well when the odd found out about all
these details that Denise was like
telling top dogs she got scared and she
was just like oh my god like I can't
believe I needed to do this and so she
called 9-1-1 what a rat I was right into
the room and be like you ain't [ __ ]
killing nobody all right miss topic why
you want to kill me but she's out there
there's got to be a reason why she wants
to kill her I want to hear a slick back
hairs when the news was arrested she was
actually surprised and she was also
speechless to learn that Topp Dogg was
her aunt she was like oh cybersex finger
bow to you
I fantasize about my aunt now there's
nothing else she can do I wanna kill her
after Marisa was arrested for
solicitation for murder she actually
escaped while she was on probation and
so she's been a fugitive ever since so
we have no idea where she's at oh he's
gonna start to file at the end she's
watching this episode of just kidding
news and she's making her way out here
to LA to catch especially David making
on his junk I know David go bucs you
gotta whip up a lid that's magical
chicken alabama's you gonna come at me
good she's gonna fit right in in the SUV
with all the agent does you're not gonna
catch her those are going to join an
Asian game become the leader and she's
gonna come after us you know I got it go
ahead but I don't mean it well what I
mean to say is please be nice I'm just
saying you had a funny ass pick why
can't I say that if I appeal I did we
all say something to Beckham or you know
it's the police's fault they caught her
on the bat yeah they caught off guard
got a little mustache you know she
probably had like the what he called the
headband hair ban or whatever they don't
take that shot you know they [ __ ] up
her hair and then like they didn't even
give her a one two three they just snap
I feel like if I was her on I'd be
[ __ ] scared well yeah he's just [ __ ]
it as a fugitive on the loose they don't
know where she's at if I was her and
then I found out that pop dog was my
aunt incest all day you're lying you're
lying
gee I love your lying it's the person
don't judge Alabama I'm pretty sure it's
okay with the cousin and occupy look at
the sole of the body there's baby it's
the same it's too late now
I wanted you to kill my own but I can't
have you killing yourself my soul mate
you know it's too late I want you to be
that person that I've met online
auntie let's get married oh so that's
we're in row Joe
Skid Row jpg my there what do you mean
Giulia is that weird it's romantic
since there was a time girl I'm sorry I
think your love shaming if I'm in that
position I would feel so betrayed
because then I just lost all trust for
toppdogg's like literally because like
you you never existed in the first or
that's who they really were in their
heart and they identified with that but
then they could have because society
judge I'm trying to figure if I was a
parent if I would if I would be
catfishing my own child but now I'm not
better [ __ ] to do I'm saying what if
your kid showed like tendencies to just
like [ __ ] go out and night and hang
out with everybody they met on the
Internet that's not like a parent like a
parent exaggerating I don't know about
that because then you there are a few
kids that do that like 40 right I did
that I think well I probably beat their
[ __ ] ass face to face first and then
making all I'm not with normal now it's
not for just a losers like during my
time because there's a bunch of keep
that's how they look you get raped all
the time though they meet people online
they go out and get their asses fun
that's how they learn nothing yeah I
hope there's a great and I've been
meeting people online since I was 14
years old but now it's trying to rape
you do that I hung out with people that
were over 18 and they drove me to raves
that's what they did in the same sort of
molested me the [ __ ] Chris Hansen
[ __ ] biology no that's that same
situation right there would they be
somebody online they talk to them they
meet up in the orig knowing some little
shits not me I be too [ __ ] lazy to
follow up as long as they're existing
and okay hello a lot of people do you
want to contact me and everybody else
you see go ahead and check the
description box below and follow our
social medias is the Gramps and
Twitter's for more videos click up there
baby
the